Hey, this
is really funny.
A little progressive media sort of inside
baseball that I think, um, uh,
is, is connected to some of the broader issues
that I've been talking about.
Um, there's a guy who has a youtube channel
named Jimmy Dore and I guess he doesn't like
Sam Cedar from the majority report, or at
least he doesn't get along with Sam, or at
least he doesn't want his audience hearing
about Sam, at least to some extent they've
had their disagreements over the years.
There are sort of from different wings of
the American left, I guess you could say.
And Jimmy Dore Has Been Caught Censoring Sam
Cedars Name and an incredibly obvious in childish
way from a Youtube Upload in much the same
way that cultural critic and arbiter of ideas.
Dave Rubin skipped over Sam's name when one
of Dave Rubin's viewers brought Sam's name
up not long ago.
And it's hilarious to see people on the I,
I mean, I guess I'll say on the left and right,
both employ this sort of same technique to
prevent Sam cedars name from appearing in
their videos.
It's like the, the, the name that shall not
be sad.
It's almost taking on some kind of like dogmatic
weirdly, uh, religious components in a sense.
Uh, you, you can't, um, you just can't say
Sam's name.
They don't like it.
So first a reminder, here's the hilarious
moment where Dave Rubin was taking audience
questions via what's called youtube super
chat.
And somebody submitted an audience question
asking Dave to debate Sam Cedar and Dave Rubin
sort of mumbled as soon as he saw Sam's name
and just moved on.
Take a look.
Uh, hey Dave, this is a very brave move on
your part.
Kudos.
Have you heard about the SJW nonsense?
I don't remember.
I don't even care about those guys.
Does it really just yet?
Honestly, doesn't matter.
So what was on screen was a message that said
you should have Sam on and destroy him.
And Ruben didn't even want to say Sam's name.
Instead of saying, oh, I don't care about
those guys.
So that was like a couple months ago.
So then this week here is the same thing happening
with Jimmy Dore when a guest mentioned Sam's
name.
Now this was a guest, not just some random
viewers.
So Jimmy Dore had to handle it a little bit
differently.
It obviously it was part of the initial recording,
but then Jimmy doors team or Jimmy Dore, I
don't know who's doing the editing over there,
edited out Sam's name in a very obvious cut
before uploading the video.
This is amazing.
You will hear them on Sam's show, play the
audio, uh, which was, uh, and then the video
which was subsequently uploaded.
And you'll notice that Sam's name was removed
from the edit in the video that was eventually
uploaded.
I mean, I usually, if I'm going to watch the
news, I either turn on your show, Sam show
or um, they're going turn.
That's usually who I go to for news.
Your shows or, um, yeah, he did do that.
So when Sam's name is mentioned, there's a
flash on the screen, which is a video transition
as we call it in video editing.
And the met the moment where Sam's mentioned
is just completely removed.
They play it again and check it out.
Sam's name just scrubbed.
It's almost like a redaction with a black
marker.
I, I mean, I usually, if I'm going to watch
the news, I either turn on your shows or,
um, the young Turks as you usually do.
I go to for news, I mean, I'm usually, if
I'm going to watch the news, I either turn
on your show, Sam show or, um, the young Turks.
That's usually who I go to for news.
Uh, your shows or, um, the young Turks,
my God.
Fuck.
And that's not even the one that they talked
about.
Yeah.
And then there's another instance of this
on Jimmy doors show.
They don't have the comparison audio, but
it's another one of these flashes where the
guest appears to say people like you and Sam
Cedar and Sam Cedars name is again removed.
Um, my solution is for the bread tubers and
all the leftovers.
People like you to go and debate with these
people and you get into their algorithm so
that people see the other side of the red
tubers and all the leftovers.
People like you to go and debate with these
people and you get into their algorithms,
you can see the flash.
It's helpful that they're jump cut that they
put in themselves, they put him in.
So what somebody said that that was in the
context of,
I think there could have been another one.
Listen, this, I mean we, we can talk about
why this is going on and, and that kind of
gets into the internal drama between Sam and
Jimmy.
The, the big takeaway is that this calls more
attention to it, right?
This is the Barbara Streisand effect, which
is named for the Streisand effect is it?
I think it was in the, around the year 2000
or so.
Um, some Paparazzi, someone I think had a,
gotten a helicopter and taking pictures of
Barbara Streisand's Malibu House in, in Malibu,
California.
And I guess Barbra Streisand didn't want those
pictures published.
So I don't know if she sued, but she tried
to get the pictures suppressed and this caused
more attention to be drawn to the pictures
that maybe nobody even really would have cared
about it.
I mean, I don't remember in the early two
thousands how much people cared about Barbara
Streisand's house.
I certainly didn't care about it at the time,
but it just drew more attention to it and
it's the exact same thing that's happening
here.
Dave Ruben won't interview me and now people
are going to his events and asking about me.
Dave Rubin recently said, I've lied about
him a bunch of times.
He never cited what those lies were.
As a result, now people are continuing to
go to his events and ask about what lies the
David Pakman, uh, tell about you or sending
super chats are tweeting him or whatever.
The same thing is happening with Sam Cedar.
People are all over.
Dave Rubin and Jimmy Dore, social media feeds
talking about Sam saying, debate Sam on and
on.
If you don't want to make this a big deal,
just ignore that.
Sam was mentioned.
This has happened with me before.
There are periods of time where my callers
and people on live streams and Twitter and
whatever, they will just hammer me with some
question about some video I did or whatever.
If I don't want to talk about it, I just ignore
it.
I don't call more attention to it and I certainly
would not do such an obvious edit to remove
the name of someone from being mentioned in
this way.
When people even call into me and they say,
Jimmy Dore this or that, I don't care.
Say Jimmy Dore.
I, if they asked me, what do you think about
what Jimmy Dore said?
I say, I don't know.
I haven't seen it because I don't watch his
show.
It would be ridiculous to go out of my way
to cut his name out or the names of other
people.
And this is sort of what I've been talking
about lately, this problem on the left, if
Jimmy Dore doesn't like Sam, just ignore the
mentions of Sam, but doing this calls more
attention to it, it generates more content
around the fact that this took place and I
truly don't get what the end game is here.
It doesn't make any sense to me.